Millions of people in the U.S. are caregivers for their family members or other loved ones. Each year, spouses, adult children, and even grandchildren provide billions of dollars worth of unpaid care to loved ones with dementia, cancer, or other long-term illnesses. And as the U.S. population ages, the number of people who need care is likely to increase. Caregiving is often portrayed as a difficult and thankless task that's so stressful that it can harm the care caregivers own physical and mental health and even make them die sooner. But some researchers argue that portrayal misses an important fact that caregiving can be a source of strength and not just stress. So how many caregivers are there in the U.S. and who are they?
美国有数百万人在为他们的家庭成员或其他爱 M 爱之人提供照料。每年，配偶、成年子女，甚至孙辈都为患有痴呆症、癌症或其他长期疾病的亲人提供价值数十亿美元的无偿照料。随着美国人口老龄化，需要照料的人数可能会增加。照料工作通常被描述为一项困难且吃力不讨好的任务，压力极大，以至于会损害照顾者自身的身体和精神健康，甚至让他们更早死亡。但一些研究人员认为，这种描述忽略了一个重要事实，即照料可以成为力量的源泉，而不仅仅是压力的来源。那么，美国有多少照顾者？他们又是谁？
What are the mental and physical health effects of caregiving? What circumstances make caregiving more stressful? And what interventions can help buffer caregivers against stress? Finally, what changes could employers, institutions, and policymakers implement to help give caregivers the support they need? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
照顾对身心健康有什么影响？什么情况下照顾会带来更大的压力？哪些干预措施可以帮助照顾者缓解压力？最后，雇主、机构和政策制定者可以实施哪些改变来帮助为照顾者提供他们所需的支持？欢迎收看《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
My guest today is Dr. William Haley, a clinical psychologist and professor in the School of Aging Studies at the University of South Florida. Dr. Haley's work focuses on understanding and helping family caregivers of older adults with chronic illness and disability, including Alzheimer's and other dementias, stroke, cancer, and terminal illness. He studies how caregiving affects people's mental and physical health and works to develop interventions to help caregivers cope. He's an APA fellow and has authored more than 170 scientific papers. Dr. Haley, thank you for joining me today. Thanks so much, Kim. I am really excited to be here. I'm a fan of the podcast and eager to share what we've learned about this.
我今天的嘉宾是威廉·海利（William Haley）博士，他是南佛罗里达大学老龄化研究学院的临床心理学家兼教授。海利博士的工作重点是理解和帮助患有慢性病和残疾的老年人的家庭照顾者，包括阿尔茨海默病和其他痴呆症、中风、癌症和绝症。他研究照顾如何影响人们的身心健康，并致力于开发干预措施来帮助照顾者应对。他是美国心理学协会（APA）会士，撰写了 170 多篇科学论文。海利博士，非常感谢您今天能来做客。非常感谢，金。我真的很高兴能来到这里。我是这个播客的粉丝，也非常渴望分享我们在这方面学到的东西。
All right. Well, then let's start by putting into context how big this issue is. I just mentioned that millions of people in the U.S. are caregivers to loved ones. Can you give us a little more detail? How many millions are we talking about and who are they? Well, as in any area, there's disagreements about which are the best figures. but I'm going to give you a range of figures. The AARP surveys every year the number of people in the United States who are caregivers, and the latest figure that they have is that 38 million Americans have provided caregiving assistance to a family member or friend without pay over the prior year. Now, some people who study this field think we ought to tone that down a little
好的。那么，让我们首先把这个问题的规模放到一个具体的背景中来考量。我刚才提到，美国有数百万人在照顾他们的亲人。您能给我们提供更多细节吗？我们讨论的是数百万中的多少人？他们又是谁？嗯，就像任何领域一样，关于哪些数据才是最好的数字存在分歧。但我会给你提供一个数据范围。美国退休人员协会（AARP）每年都会调查美国照顾者的数量，他们拥有的最新数据显示，过去一年中，有 3800 万美国人无偿向家庭成员或朋友提供过照料帮助。现在，一些研究该领域的人认为我们应该稍微淡化这个数字，
because those numbers will include people who are doing very short bursts of caregiving and are not really doing long-term caregiving, but the numbers who are doing extensive caregiving are also extensive. So, for example, there was a 2016 report from the National Academies of Sciences that showed that 17 million, 17.7 million actually are caring for people who have problems with mobility, self-care, or activities of daily living. So that's a pretty good chunk of that. And also, as part of that 17.7 million, there are 8.5 million who are doing very heavy caregiving. So they're caring for people with Alzheimer's, other dementias, and people with other conditions who have two or more limits and activities of daily living. So it's a big number.
因为这些数字将包括那些只进行非常短期的照料、并非真正从事长期照料的人，但从事广泛照料的人数也很庞大。例如，美国国家科学院（National Academies of Sciences）2016 年的一份报告显示，有 1700 万人，准确地说是 1770 万人，正在照顾那些在移动能力、自我照顾或日常生活活动方面遇到问题的人。所以这占据了其中相当大的比重。此外，在 这 1770 万人中，有 850 万人正在承担非常繁重的照料工作。也就是说，他们在照顾患有阿尔茨海默病、其他痴呆症以及患有其他疾病、日常生活活动有两个或更多受限的人。所以这是一个很大的数字。
And, you know, you mentioned, you know, the economic issues. Something like 60% of people who are caregivers are also in the labor force. And so they're trying to juggle providing care for mom or grandmother or a spouse and also the workplace. And that can be really challenging. Now, there's a common portrayal in the media that caregiving is stressful and thankless and that it's so stressful that caregivers die sooner than non-caregivers. But you have argued for a much more nuanced view of caregiving. What have you found and how does caregiving affect people's mental and physical health? So first of all, it is clearly the case that caregiving can be extremely stressful and that it can be very challenging, it can be very isolating, and that it does lead to increases in depression and anxiety, and many people feel burdened from it.
而且，你知道的，你刚才提到了经济问题。大约 60% 的照顾者同时也身处劳动力市场。因此，他们试图在照顾妈妈、祖母或配偶与工作之间进行平衡，这可能会非常具有挑战性。现在，媒体上普遍有一种描绘，认为照顾工作压力大且吃力不讨好，压力大到照顾者比非照顾者死得更早。但你一直主张对照顾持更细致的看法。你发现了什么？照顾又是如何影响人们的身心健康呢？首先，显而易见的是，照顾工作确实压力极大，非常具有挑战性，也极其孤立，它确实会导致抑郁和焦虑的增加，许多人也因此感到负担重重。
But the part that I think where we've kind of missed the boat in terms of public portrayals of caregiving, there were some very good early studies that found some very negative effect. but they were relatively small samples and followed people, either not at all or over very limited periods of time. So a 1999 study published in the Journal American Medical Association reported that for spouses who were caring for a disabled husband or wife, that if they reported any strain in doing caregiving, they had 63% higher mortality rates over a four-year period than spouses who were not doing any caregiving. That study has been very widely reported. It was the best research to date on the topic.
但在我看来，我们在公众对照顾的描绘中有点偏离方向的部分在于，早期有一些非常好的研究发现了一些非常负面的影响，但它们的样本相对较小，对人们的追踪时间要么没有，要么非常有限。因此，1999 年发表在《美国医学会杂志》（Journal American Medical Association）上的一项研究报告称，对于照顾残疾丈夫或妻子的配偶来说，如果他们在进行照顾时报告了任何压力，他们在四年内的死亡率比没有进行任何照顾的配偶高出 63%。该研究得到了广泛报道。这是迄今为止关于该主题的最佳研究。
But now there have been over a dozen studies of caregiving and mortality. And in fact, what they have found, and our group has been one that has contributed to this, somewhere in the range of 16% to 18% lower mortality among people who are caregivers. So the early finding there was just inaccurate. And it was an outlier. There's a similar story is the case when we look at biomarkers that may be affected by stress. And some early work that used samples of dementia caregivers from the community who had sought help, they found that those caregivers compared to non-caregivers had elevations in various indices of inflammation,
但现在已经有十多项关于照顾与死亡率的研究。事实上，他们发现的结果——我们的团队也是贡献者之一——照顾者的死亡率大约比其他人低 16% 到 18%。因此，早期的那个发现在某种程度上是不准确的。它是一个异常值。当我们观察可能受压力影响的生物标志物时，也有类似的情况。在早期的一些研究中，他们使用了社区中寻求帮助的痴呆症照顾者样本，发现这些照顾者与非照顾者相比，炎症的各种指标有所升高，
and they had immune system dysfunction. Another group found shortened telomere length in people who had been, caregiving for a long time. That again was done with a small sample. We've done a systematic review and meta-analysis of all the research in this area. We have found there were only very small effects of caregiving on inflammation. They're not of a magnitude to affect health. And we found no changes over a nine-year period in a group of caregivers who had not previously been caregivers. they show no telomere shortening and no increases in inflammation compared to a non-caregiving group. So I think we can pretty well reassure people that physical health impact of caregiving
并且他们的免疫系统功能出现了失调。另一个研究小组发现，长期照顾他人的人的端粒长度缩短了。这同样是在一个小样本上进行的。我们对该领域的所有研究进行了系统性回顾和荟萃分析。我们发现照顾对炎症的影响非常小。它们的量级不足以影响健康。我们在九年内对一组以前没有担任过照顾者的人群进行了观察，没有发现任何变化，与非照顾者群体相比，他们没有表现出端粒缩短，也没有表现出炎症增加。因此，我认为我们可以相当好地向人们保证，照顾对身体健康的负面影响
is not as bad as they once thought, but we still have to be concerned about psychological distress. And you mentioned shortened telomeres. I just want to make sure our listeners understand that's a genetic factor, right? And what might that mean? Well, the idea is that with stress, and with aging, there's a shortening of telomeres, and that shorter telomeres generally are associated with lower life expectancy. So that was a very alarming early study, but it was done with a small sample, and the people were not tracked over time to see whether their telomeres actually shortened.
并没有人们曾经想象的那么糟糕，但我们仍然需要关注心理痛苦。你提到了端粒缩短。我只是想确保我们的听众明白，这是一个遗传因素，对吧？这可能意味着什么？嗯，这个观点是，随着压力和衰老，端粒会缩短，而较短的端粒通常与较低的预期寿命相关。所以那是一项非常令人担忧的早期研究，但它是在一个小样本上进行的，而且没有对这些人进行长期追踪，以观察他们的端粒是否真的缩短了。
And again, as I mentioned, in our work, we worked with a big population-based study, the regard study, where we were able to track people who had blood assays repeatedly over a period of years, and we did not see that. So why is it so important to change this doomsday narrative around caregiving? Well, first of all, I think it's important because so many Americans now are becoming caregivers, and so many Americans now may be fearful of the health consequences of care. And my good colleague David Roth, who has worked closely with me on most of these papers, he has drawn an analogy that basically caregiving is not smoking cigarettes.
而且，正如我所提到的，在我们的工作中，我们研究了一个大型基于人群的研究，即“中风地理和地区差异原因”（REGARDS）研究，在那里我们能够对多年来多次采集血液检测样本的人群进行追踪，我们并没有看到那种情况。那么，为什么改变这种围绕照顾的末日叙事如此重要？嗯，首先，我认为这很重要，因为现在有这么多的美国人正在成为照顾者，而这么多的美国人现在可能对照顾带来的健康后果感到恐惧。我和我的好同事大卫·罗斯（David Roth）在这篇论文的大多数研究中都与我紧密合作，他打了一个比方，基本上照顾并不等同于吸烟。
It's not a risk factor of that magnitude. Now, that said, we are not doing a good job as a society of supporting our caregivers. We found, for example, the average person who is a dementia caregiver puts in about 60 hours a week providing care for a person at home. And that is just astonishing. It's a full-time job, and some people do that while, in fact, they are employed. And we are not providing them, as many other countries do, with the free supports of people coming in and bathe and dress their relative, of assisted living that is paid for, not out of pocket paid for by, say, Medicare. Medicare does not pay for these kind of home care duties, which is viewed as custodial and not rehabilitative. So we have big gaps in what we're
它没有那么大程度的风险因素。话虽如此，作为一个社会，我们在支持照顾者方面做得还不够。例如，我们发现照顾痴呆症患者的普通人每周花在大约 60 小时在家照顾一个人上。这简直令人吃力。这是一份全职工作，有些人甚至在有工作的同时还要这样做。而且我们没有像许多其他国家那样，为他们提供免费支持，比如有人上门帮亲人洗澡和穿衣，提供由医疗保险（Medicare）而非自费支付的辅助生活。医疗保险不支付这些日常居家照料费用，这些被视为日常照料而非康复服务。因此，我们在帮助
doing to help people who are caregivers. And you mentioned Medicare, and I'm just wondering what should the role of insurers be, whether they're public or private? So our Medicare system is set up strictly to manage medical conditions. And so we run into this and not to cover long-term care. It won't pay for nursing home care over an extended period of time. It won't pay for somebody to come in and bathe and dress mom. It might pay for physical therapy if the person was able to show benefit for that over a short period of time. What that means is that, you know, you have these absurdities that where, for example, a person with dementia could have a very expensive heart transplant or they could have hip replacement or knee replacement surgery. That would be very expensive, but yet Medicare will not cover.
照顾者方面存在巨大的漏洞。你提到了医疗保险，我只是想知道保险公司的角色应该是什么，无论是公共的还是私人的？所以我们的医疗保险系统纯粹是为了管理医疗状况而设立的。因此我们遇到了这种情况，而不是为了涵盖长期护理。它不会支付长期护理院的费用。它不会支付别人上门帮妈妈洗澡和穿衣的费用。如果此人在短时间内能够证明从中受益，它可能会支付物理治疗的费用。这意味着，你知道的，你会遇到这些荒谬的情况，例如，患有痴呆症的人可以做非常昂贵的心脏移植手术，或者他们可以做髋关节置换或膝关节置换手术。这将非常昂贵，然而医疗保险却不会涵盖
having someone to come in and bathe and manage the toileting of a parent while the caregiver works. So we've just got a mismatch of Medicare not really seeing it as its mission to cover long-term care, when long-term care is now the thing that caregivers end up doing and having to pay for out of pocket. So let me ask you a question about the circumstances that do make caregiving more stressful. What are some of those factors? Well, first of all, a lot of this research has been done with people who are caregivers for Alzheimer's disease and other dementias. And we know that in that circumstance, you know, families do a lot of things to help that person. They take over managing finances.
在照顾者工作时，请人上门帮父母洗澡和处理如厕问题。因此，我们遇到了医疗保险并不真正认为其使命是涵盖长期护理的不匹配情况，而长期护理现在正是照顾者最终不得不做并必须自掏腰包的事情。那么，请问你一个关于确实会增加照顾压力的环境的问题。其中一些因素是什么？嗯，首先，很多这样的研究都是针对阿尔茨海默病和其他痴呆症的照顾者进行的。我们知道，在这种情况下，你知道，家庭为帮助那个人做了很多事情。他们接管了财务管理。
They'll take over bathing and dressing of a relative. They'll take over management of incontinence, so they're changing diapers or doing bowel and bladder care. But the things that dementia caregivers tell us are most stressful are behavioral problems. And we've shown this in many studies, as of other colleagues, the person with dementia will begin to wander, they'll get agitated, they'll become depressed and cry, they may wander out and get lost, they may say embarrassing things in public. And so for a person who's a dementia caregiver, they face this challenge of, a person who was once very rational to them and a peer and who was fully cognitively able,
他们接管了亲属的洗澡和穿衣。他们接管了大便失禁的管理，因此他们要换尿布或进行肠道和膀胱护理。但痴呆症照顾者告诉我们压力最大的事情是行为问题。我们在许多研究中都证明了这一点，正如其他同事一样，痴呆症患者会开始游荡、变得焦躁不安、变得抑郁和哭泣、他们可能会游荡出去迷路、他们可能会在公共场合说令人尴尬的话。因此，对于一个痴呆症照顾者来说，他们面临着这样的挑战：一个曾经对他们来说非常理性、是同龄人且完全具备认知能力的人，
now behaving in strange ways that are stressful. And so one of the things we have to do, and there are very good counseling interventions that psychologists and others can implement, we can teach caregivers how to communicate with a person with dementia. Some key issues in that. You don't argue with a person with dementia. They've lost their high. higher abilities of reasoning. And so explaining to them carefully why they want to go to the doctor or why they need to go to the doctor when they don't want to or explaining to them that they've just misplaced their keys, that nobody has taken them. Those are not going to work very well. And so, you know, so we can't explain.
现在却表现出奇怪的、令人痛苦的行为。因此，我们必须做的事情之一——心理学家和其他人可以实施非常好的咨询干预——我们可以教照顾者如何与痴呆症患者沟通。这其中的一些关键问题是。你不要跟痴呆症患者争辩。他们已经失去了高级的推理能力。因此，当他们不想去或者需要去的时候，小心翼翼地向他们解释为什么要去看医生，或者向他们解释他们的钥匙只是放错地方了、没有人拿走。这些方法是行不通的。所以，你知道的，所以我们无法解释。
We can't argue. And very key is that people with dementia, in a sense, they lose the words, but they get the music. if you think of it that way. So they'll see your nonverbal behaviors. Even if you're learning to kind of talk calmly, if you're enraged and your facial expression shows it, your arms show that you're distressed, your body posture. So we have to help caregivers to learn how to communicate in a way where they are not showing their distress. And we can teach caregivers some, in a way I think of it as a jiu-jitsu move. We're using their memory. loss, you know, against them. If we can distract a person with dementia, I had one caregiver found
我们不能争辩。非常关键的一点是，从某种意义上说，痴呆症患者失去了词汇，但他们理解了旋律。如果你这样想的话。因此，他们会看到你的非语言行为。即使你在努力冷静地说话，如果你勃然大怒并且你的面部表情表现出来了，你的手臂表现出你很痛苦，你的身体姿势也是如此。因此，我们必须帮助照顾者学习如何以不显露痛苦的方式进行沟通。我们可以教照顾者一些，在某种程度上我认为这就像柔术动作。我们利用他们的记忆丧失，你知道的，来对付他们。如果我们能分散痴呆症患者的注意力，我曾有一位照顾者发现
that it worked. She carried around some candies. And if she put a candy in her husband's mouth, he suddenly forgot what he was arguing about. Or if the caregiver can go outside for a few minutes, right? And just disengage from the stressful circumstance. Now, you've got to make sure the person that's safe. If I'm a caregiver, where do I go to learn these skills? Because they're obviously not taught in school or any place else where you might pick up this kind of information? First place I would urge people to go would be to see a clinical gerosychologist. And the APA now, I'm very pleased, actually has board certified people in gerosychology. Unfortunately, only 3% of APA members identify gerosychology as their specialty.
这很管用。她随身带了一些糖果。如果她把一颗糖放进她丈夫的嘴里，他突然就忘了他在争论什么。或者如果照顾者可以出去几分钟，对吧？从压力的环境中抽离出来。现在，你必须确保那个人的安全。如果我是个照顾者，我去哪里学习这些技能呢？因为学校或其他任何可能让你学到这种信息的地方显然都没有教过这些？我敦促人们去的第一地方是去看临床老年心理学家。我很欣慰，现在 APA 实际上拥有了老年心理学认证人员。不幸的是，只有 3% 的 APA 成员将老年心理学确定为他们的专业。
So we have to do a lot better job of increasing the cadre of people there. But all psychologists are going to see more older adults and more caregivers. If you're treating middle-aged people, you're going to be having caregiving as a major stressful experience. So a variety of psychotherapists and counselors can be helpful, social workers. A key place is for people to go as the Alzheimer's Association. The Alzheimer's Association offers support groups, educational programs. I'll also mention the Alzheimer's Foundation of America.
所以我们在增加这方面的人才队伍方面还有很多工作要做。但所有的心理学家都将看到更多的老年人和更多的照顾者。如果你在治疗中年人，你就会把照顾视为主要的压力体验。因此，各种心理治疗师和辅导员可以提供帮助，社会工作者也是如此。人们可以去的一个关键地方是阿尔茨海默病协会（Alzheimer's Association）。阿尔茨海默病协会提供支持小组、教育项目。我还要提到美国阿尔茨海默病基金会（Alzheimer's Foundation of America）。
They do a lot of webinars that can help caregivers learn caregiving skills. There's also great information, for example, on the Alzheimer's Association and the National Institute on Aging websites. And the NIA, National Institute on Aging, in particular, has fact sheets that tell people about Alzheimer's or other forms of dementia. They look for places where people can get assistance. They provide advice about communication. One last place I want to mention, really, too.
他们举办了许多网络研讨会，可以帮助照顾者学习照顾技能。例如，阿尔茨海默病协会和国家老龄化研究所（National Institute on Aging）的网站上也有大量极好的信息。尤其是国家老龄化研究所，拥有向人们介绍阿尔茨海默病或其他形式痴呆症的事实说明书。他们寻找人们可以获得帮助的地方。他们提供关于沟通的建议。我还要提及的最后一个地方，事实上，有两个。
One of those is area agencies on aging. So the area agencies on aging are federally funded, and they are sources. They know the local resources. They know where to send people. And a final kind of related resource is there's now a group of professionals who have used the term geriatric care management, but they're now tending to call themselves life care managers. And these are sort of hyper-local care managers very popular in Florida. You know, if mom has moved to Florida and you're in Massachusetts, you'd probably don't want to have to commute frequently
其中之一是老龄化地区机构。因此，老龄化地区机构是由联邦资助的，它们是资源。他们了解当地的资源。他们知道该把人送到哪里去。最后一个相关的资源是，现在有一群专业人员，他们曾经使用过“老年护理管理”这个词，但他们现在倾向于称自己为“生活护理管理者”。这些是超级本地化的护理管理者，在佛罗里达州非常受欢迎。你知道，如果妈妈搬到了佛罗里达州而你在马萨诸塞州，你可能不想经常通勤
to come check on mom and make sure she gets to physical therapy. And so these geriatric care managers, they know the local resources, they know what funding might be available, they know about transportation, they know about meal programs. So there are a lot of great resources. I want to mention we also have a large evidence based now that there are a variety of effective psychological interventions that improve the well-being of caregiving. And these include cognitive behavioral therapy, mindfulness therapy, really a variety of psychoeducational approaches. And let me mention that in some studies that I've been a part of where we track people long after they have had counseling, we find that rates of nursing home placement can be diminished by people having caregiving counseling.
来查看妈妈并确保她去进行物理治疗。因此，这些老年护理管理者，他们了解当地的资源，他们知道可能会有哪些资金支持，他们了解交通情况，他们了解膳食计划。所以有很多极好的资源。我想提一下，我们现在也有大量的循证依据表明，有各种有效的心理干预措施可以改善照顾者的福祉。这些包括认知行为疗法、正念疗法，以及各种各样的心理教育方法。让我提及的是，在我参与的一些研究中，我们对接受过咨询很久之后的人进行了追踪，我们发现接受过照顾咨询的人，其入住疗养院的比率可以降低。
And that's because if you build people in with the skills and the social supports to be able to manage dementia, even if you only treat them, in this case, we did a study working with colleagues at New York University. they only gave six sessions of family and individual counseling. But years later, those sessions were enough to help prevent and delay nursing home placement. I want to talk for a minute about the multiple roles that caregivers may play. You know, I'm thinking when my mother became terminally ill, my father became her caregiver. And he was very resistant to having others come into the home to help her, even though he himself was in his mid-80s. and it was really hard to handle all of her needs alone.
这是因为如果你为人们建立技能和社会支持，使他们能够应对痴呆症，即使你只治疗他们——在这个案例中，我们与纽约大学（New York University）的同事合作进行了一项研究，他们只进行了六次家庭和个人咨询。但多年以后，这些咨询足以帮助预防和推迟入住疗养院。我想花一分钟时间谈谈照顾者可能扮演的多重角色。你知道，我在想，当我母亲身患绝症时，我父亲成了她的照顾者。尽管他自己已经八十多岁了，但他非常抵触让其他人来家里帮忙，
And I don't think that's uncommon where these roles get commingled to the point where the partner isn't doing a good job either as a spouse or a caregiver. What kind of advice do you have for spouses who end up as caregivers for their partners or even for other family members who are trying to navigate that kind of a situation? One key thing that we see is oftentimes people who are caregivers are very used to helping others, but they're not used to asking others to give them help. And so one strategy I've used in a counseling work has been to have them reflect on how good they felt when they helped other people.
而且独自应付她所有的需求真的很难。我认为这种情况并不少见，这些角色相互交织，以至于伴侣既没有扮演好配偶的角色，也没有扮演好照顾者的角色。对于最终成为伴侣照顾者的配偶，或者甚至对于试图应对这种局势的其他家庭成员，你有什么建议？我们看到的一个关键情况是，通常担任照顾者的人非常习惯于帮助别人，但他们不习惯请求别人给予他们帮助。因此，我在咨询工作中采用的一种策略是让他们反思他们在帮助别人时感觉有多好。
So perhaps giving, you know, if you have nearby family who can help, giving them a chance to be of some assistance. Now, one thing, people will often fear that family isn't willing to come and sit with dad all day. but even if you can get brief breaks, if you can get a two-hour respite so that you can go out and maybe even just go shopping or sit in the park. Taking breaks from caregiving is important. Or some families have found ways, you know, you mentioned the multiple roles.
所以也许可以给予，你知道的，如果你有附近的家人可以帮忙，给他们一个提供一些协助的机会。现在，有一件事，人们常常担心家人不愿整天坐着陪爸爸，但即使你能得到短暂的喘息，如果你能得到两个小时的休息，这样你就可以出去，甚至只是去买东西或坐在公园里。从照顾中抽出时间休息是很重要的。或者有些家庭找到了方法，你提到了多重角色。
Somebody has to take over the finances. Somebody has to figure out how to handle health insurance claims. Some people have to figure out how to get medications filled, transportation, you know, managing bowel and bladder, the personal care. And so some of those things can be farmed out a little better without having people necessarily in the home. But you're exactly right. A lot of caregivers, I'm afraid they'll say, well, I'll do it when I need it, when I really
总得有人接管财务。总得有人弄清楚如何处理健康保险索赔。有些人必须弄清楚如何配药、解决交通问题、处理肠道和膀胱问题以及个人护理。因此，其中一些事情可以更好地分包出去，而不必一定让其他人呆在家里的。但你完全说得对。很多照顾者，我担心他们会说，好吧，当我需要它时我会做的，当我真正
need it. Unfortunately, their definition is they don't really need it until they're in crisis until they fall and break a hip or they, you know, develop a medical condition that makes them unable to provide care. So, yeah, we've got to do a better job of that. And part of the problem is, though, that we largely have to pay out of pocket for these kind of services, like someone coming into the home. So having better support from, you know, federal government and state and local governments, or even groups like our churches would be a way that we could make that easier and more palatable for people.
需要它的时候。不幸的是，他们的定义是，在他们处于危机之中、直到他们摔倒并骨折或者他们患上了使他们无法提供照顾的医疗状况之前，他们并不真正需要它。所以，是的，我们在这方面必须做得更好。然而，部分问题在于，对于这类服务，比如有人上门服务，我们主要必须自掏腰包。因此，获得来自联邦政府、州和地方政府的更好支持，或者甚至像我们的教堂这样的团体的支持，将是我们使人们更容易、更乐于接受这些服务的一种方式。
Have you looked much at this whole movement toward what they used to call where I live, the village so that people who were still well and able to take care of themselves would join in and help and take older people shopping or help people so that they could basically age in place. Is that catching on? There's a broader movement that's called age-friendly communities. And here in Florida, we have a number of places that have been designated as age-friendly communities. My colleague, Dr. Kathy Black, who's at University of South Florida, Sarasota,
你是否对这整个朝向我住的地方过去称之为“村庄”的运动做过很多研究？这样，那些仍然健康且能够照顾自己的人就会加入并提供帮助，带老年人去购物或提供帮助，这样他们基本上就可以就地养老。这种做法正在流行吗起效吗？有一项更广泛的运动被称为“老年友好型社区”（age-friendly communities）。在佛罗里达州，我们有许多地方被指定为老年友好型社区。我的同事凯西·布莱克（Kathy Black）博士，她是南佛罗里达州萨拉索塔分校的教授，
has been a leader in that movement. And there the idea is to educate the whole community, to make the whole community aging friendly, like having sidewalks and benches and things. But there's a further movement called dementia-friendly communities. And that's a beautiful thing. The idea is, sure, you could teach high school students and grade school children about what to do if they see a person who's cognitive impaired. You can teach people in stores, police, restaurants, all to do things that if they spot a person with cognitive impairment, that they could do something helpful. There's also been related to that a beautiful movement for dementia cafes, where what they do is have an afternoon a week where they welcome people with dementia and their family caregivers
一直是该运动的领导者。那里的想法是教育整个社区，使整个社区变得对老年人友好，比如铺设人行道、长椅等。但还有一项更进一步的运动被称为“痴呆症友好型社区”（dementia-friendly communities）。这是一件美好的事情。这个想法是，当然，你可以教高中生和学龄儿童在看到有认知障碍的人时该怎么做。你可以教商店、警察、餐馆里的所有人做一些事情，如果他们发现有认知障碍的人，他们可以做一些有帮助的事情。与此相关的还有一个美好的运动，即“痴呆症咖啡馆”（dementia cafes），他们的做法是每周有一个下午，欢迎痴呆症患者及其家庭照顾者
into a coffee house type environment, and they play gentle music, and the people with dementia typically love music. They may respond to music in ways they don't to other communication, and the caregivers have a chance to be together. So there's tons of innovations that we can do, and that we need to be doing much more of. Now, you've been studying caregiving for decades. How did you first get interested in this field? This was actually, I can date it to 1981. So I had just finished my psychology internship at the University of Washington, Seattle, and I started a postdoctoral fellowship in geriatric clinical psychology.
进入咖啡馆式的环境，他们播放柔和的音乐，痴呆症患者通常非常喜欢音乐。他们对音乐的反应可能会超过对其他沟通方式的反应，而照顾者也有机会聚在一起。因此，我们可以做、并且需要做更多的创新有成千上万种。现在，你研究照顾工作已经几十年了。你最初是怎么对这个领域产生兴趣的？这其实可以追溯到 1981 年。当时我刚完成在西雅图华盛顿大学的心理学实习，并开始了一项老年临床心理学博士后研究。
And I'll confess the reason that I started that postdoctoral fellowship was not out of a deep love and interest of geriatrics, but I went on the academic job market and applied for 22 jobs and didn't. get one. So I needed to make a fresh start. And so my first clinic assignment was in a unit called an outpatient clinic called the Geriatric and Family Services Clinic. And it was one of the first dementia clinics in the United States. This is at the University of Washington, Seattle. And my primary job was to go and do psychological testing. Psychologists play a key role in assessing memory, intelligence, visual spatial skills, et cetera. And that was my main job.
我坦白说，我开始那个博士后研究并不是出于对老年学的一往情深和热爱，而是因为我进入了学术就业市场，申请了 22 个工作却一个都没拿到。我需要重新开始。因此，我的第一个诊所分配是在一个名为老年与家庭服务诊所的门诊部。那是美国最早的痴呆症诊所之一。这是在西雅图华盛顿大学。我的主要工作是去进行心理测试。心理学家在评估记忆、智力、视觉空间技能等方面发挥着关键作用。那是我的主要工作，
and they're still mainstays. But I found I was fascinated by the people who brought the person with dementia in, the caregivers. And at this time, 1981, there was no functioning Alzheimer's Association. There were no self-help groups. There were no books. But I found as a psychologist, I could teach people the ABCs, the antecedents of the behavior problems their relatives had,
而且它们仍然是支柱。但我发现我被那些把痴呆症患者带来的人——照顾者深深吸引了。在当时，即 1981 年，还没有运作良好的阿尔茨海默病协会。没有自助小组。没有书。但我发现作为一名心理学家，我可以教人们 ABC 法则，即他们的亲属所具有的行为问题的前因，
understanding the behavior, how to respond differently to it, how to communicate. And I found I had some of the most. grateful clients I had ever worked with. These regular folks who had a spouse or a parent developed dementia and they were bewildered. And I found I could readily help them. So I made it my sort of mission in my career to go on with this. And I subsequently learned not only was it great working with these families to help them and the most gratifying work I've ever done. You see amazing examples of people providing care under very difficult circumstances, wonderful people. But I also really realized that it was a
理解行为，如何以不同的方式对此做出反应，如何进行沟通。我发现我拥有了一些我共事过的最心怀感激的客户。这些普通人，他们的配偶或父母患上了痴呆症，他们感到迷惑不解。我发现我能够轻而易举地帮助他们。所以我把这作为我职业生涯的一种使命继续下去。我随后了解到，不仅与这些家庭合作以帮助他们非常棒，这也是我做过的最令人欣慰的工作。你看到了在非常困难的环境下提供照顾的人们的惊人例子，都是些了不起的人。但我也真正意识到，这是一个
great way to study psychological stress. So that's led us into studying stress process models and how those can predict well-being, how they might predict physical changes that people experience with caregiving, how we can use that to design interventions. So I've got to say it's been a great adventure. And then Beyond that, I began to realize the enormity of this issue of people with stroke, with cancer, with end-of-life issues, and they all face their unique problems. So it's a gratifying area, and I really believe every psychologist needs to know something about helping caregivers, because we're all going to see it in our practice. How does the United States compare to other countries regarding caregiving?
研究心理压力的绝佳途径。因此，这引导我们去研究压力过程模型以及它们如何能够预测福祉，它们如何能够预测人们在照顾过程中经历的身体变化，以及我们如何利用这一点来设计干预措施。所以我得说这是一次伟大的冒险。除此之外，我开始意识到中风患者、癌症患者和临终关怀问题这一巨大议题，他们都面临着各自独特的问题。因此，这是一个令人欣慰的领域，我真的相信每个心理学家都需要了解一些关于如何帮助照顾者的知识，因为我们都会在实践中遇到这种情况。美国在照顾方面与其他国家相比如何？
Are there any nations that have done an exemplary job figuring out how to give family caregivers the support that they need? So I'm not an expert on the international caregiving issues, but I can tell you I know that in Western Europe and in England, far more resources are provided, ranging from transportation to in-home caregiver work to models where employers are required to give people, time off to provide care, which we largely don't do in the United States. And so, yes, we can look to some of those, particularly the ones I know about are in Western Europe and in the UK, where the government is much more generous about providing these services. Now, they're going to be expensive. But on the other hand, we've got a mentality that, gee, that's a family problem. It's up to the family to take care of it. Maybe that worked okay in 1900 when it was rare that
有没有哪个国家在摸索如何为家庭照顾者提供所需支持方面做出了表率？所以，我不是国际照顾问题的专家，但我可以告诉你，我知道在西欧和英国，提供了更多的资源，从交通到居家照顾者工作，再到要求雇主给予人们照顾假期的雇主模式，而我们在美国基本上没有这样做。所以，是的，我们可以借鉴其中的一些，特别是据我所知的那些在西欧和英国的模式，那里的政府在提供这些服务方面要慷慨得多。当然，它们会很昂贵。但另一方面，我们有一种心态，天哪，那是家庭的问题。这取决于家庭来照顾。也许在 1900 年人们很少活到晚年时，这种心态还算行得通。现在人们大都能活到八十多岁。因此，事实上，我们可以预料会有许多患有痴呆症和严重损伤的人。所以我们必须在这方面做得更好。我要提到的是，美国在 2018 年通过了一项名为《照料家人法案》（RAISE Family Caregiver Act）的联邦立法。它是 R-A-I-S-E。因此，该立法基本上促成了几个委员会的成立，这些委员会一直在非常努力地制定具体的政策提案。他们在 2022 年发布了这些提案。因此，如果您有兴趣，或者您的任何听众有兴趣，我很乐意向他们推荐，或者他们可以查阅《照料家人法案》。所以我们已经起步了，但是天哪，我们还有很长的路要走。这让我想到了一个问题：
people live to late life. Now people are largely living into their 80s. And so we can expect to have many people with dementia and severe impairments as a matter of fact. So we've got to get much better at this. I will mention that there was federal legislation passed in 2018 in the United States called the Raised Family Caregiver Act. It's R-A-I-S-E. And so that legislation basically, led to the establishment of some committees that have been working very hard to develop specific policy proposals. And they released those in 2022. And so if you're interested or if any of your listeners are interested, I'd be glad to refer them or they can look up the Ray's Caregiver Act. So we've made a start, but boy, we've got a long way to go. And that brings me to the question of
如何为此做好准备，因为我们婴儿潮一代正在变老，而且，你知道的，除非我们做好准备，否则这可能会对我们的家庭和社会造成相当大的负担。我只是在想，我们大多数现在还不是照顾者的人，将来可能会成为照顾者。我们应该做些什么来为之做准备呢？我们都应该做的一件事是管理我们的法律和财务事务。例如，医疗保险不会支付长期的疗养院护理费用，但医疗补助（Medicaid）会，而你只有在收入和资源较少的情况下才有资格获得医疗补助。因此，人们可以做的一件事，而且是完全合法的，就是会见老龄法律或家庭律师，并在年长的家庭成员还有能力这样做的时候，
how to be ready for this because we baby boomers are getting older and, you know, it could become quite a burden on our families and on society unless we prepare. And I'm just wondering most of us who are not caregivers right now, we might become caregivers in the future. What should we be doing to prepare for this? One thing we all ought to be doing is managing our legal and financial affairs. So, for example, Medicare will not pay for long-term nursing home care, but Medicaid will, but you only qualify for Medicaid if you have low amounts of income and resources. So one thing that people can do, and that's perfectly legal, is to meet with an elder law or family attorney and place the older family members, while they're competent to do this,
将他们的资金放入信托中。因此，如果你设立了正确类型的信托，那么当你到了不得不这样做的时候，如果你需要照顾，你的家庭成员就可以用这些资源来提供。但是，如果你到了要住进疗养院的地步——这可能每年花费你 10 万美元——那将会非常快地摧毁一个家庭，你知道的，大多数家庭。但如果你把钱放在信托里，你可能就有资格获得医疗补助，这基本上可以支付你的疗养院费用。我们还可以购买长期护理保险。不幸的是，很少有美国人拥有它，
they may place their funds in a trust. And so if you have the right kind of trust set up, then when you're at a point where you have to, if you need care, your family members can provide it with these resources. But if you're at a point where you're going to go into a nursing home, which could cost you $100,000 a year, that will wipe out a family, you know, very quickly, most families. But if you had that money in trust, you might be eligible for Medicaid, which would largely cover your nursing home expenses. We can also get long-term care insurance. Unfortunately, very few Americans have that,
而且当你年龄较大时购买会非常昂贵。但如果你在年轻时购买，那就是一个机会。但我认为实际上非常令人鼓舞的一件事是。我们看到越来越多的年轻人参与到照顾中来。我在我的大学里教授一门老龄化心理学课程，事实上，我们教授许多面向本科生的课程，我们在关于老龄化的一般教育课程中每年覆盖 4000 多名学生。但这些学生都在学习一些关于照顾和与
and it's very expensive to get when you're older. But if you get it when you're younger, that's an opportunity. But one thing I think is actually very encouraging. We're seeing more younger people involved in caregiving. I teach a class in psychology of aging at my university, and in fact, we teach a lot of courses that reach, undergraduates, we reach over 4,000 a year in general education courses about aging. But those students are all learning something about caregiving and about communicating with
痴呆症患者沟通的知识。我们在大学水平上教导人们这方面的知识还可以做得更好。我要提到的另一件事是，家庭需要就这些事情进行对话，而不是等到妈妈或爸爸患上晚期痴呆症时才去讨论照顾问题。因此，这些是我们本可以做得更好的事情，我希望我们能够做到。我想花一分钟时间谈谈照顾中的一些人口统计学和文化差异。我读到过关于黑人家庭等如何倾向于在家里而不是在机构中处理照顾工作的报道。我想知道，你是否发现确实如此？
people with dementia. We could do a much better job of teaching people, say, at a college level, about this. The other thing I will mention is that families need to have conversations about these things, not just wait till mom or dad is with advanced dementia, to have discussions about caregiving. So these are things we could do a much better job about, and I hope that we will. I want to talk for a minute about some of the demographic and cultural differences in caregiving. I was reading about how black families, for example, tend to be more likely to handle caregiving at home as opposed to in institutions. And I'm wondering, have you found that this is the case?
如果是这样，这是一种文化现象还是财务原因？所以我实际上开始进行大部分照顾研究时，我是在阿拉巴马大学伯明翰分校（University of Alabama at Birmingham）。在伯明翰，当地 50% 的人口是黑人。而在阿拉巴马州，这一比例是 25%。我当时正在看诊。我被家庭对待痴呆症的文化差异深深地震惊了。在黑人社区，家庭成员极力淡化他们的亲属受损程度是非常普遍的，他们告诉我们，他们在早年就进行过讨论，关于照顾如何成为他们文化的一部分以及他们可以预期要做的事情的一部分。所以这并没有真正被视为意外。
And if so, is it a cultural thing or is it financial? So I've actually started doing much of my caregiving research when I was at the University. of Alabama at Birmingham. And in Birmingham, 50% of the local population is black. And in a state of Alabama, 25%. I was seeing patients at the time. And I was very struck by the cultural differences in how families approach dementia. In the black community, very common for family members to minimize how impaired their family member is, to have told us that they've had early life discussions about how caregiving is a part of their culture and a part of what they can expect to do. And so it's not really taken as a surprise.
北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校（University of North Carolina Chapel Hill）有一位杰出的社会学家佩吉·迪尔沃思-安德森（Peggy Dilworth Anderson），她是一名黑人，一直在研究这些文化问题。她称之为“照顾的文化正当性”，因此在黑人家庭中，它被视为正常家庭角色的一部分。它不被视为某种你好像在放弃什么的东西。它被视为一种被期望的事情，并且从很小的年龄就开始讨论。确实，黑人家庭将亲属送入疗养院的可能性较小。其中一些原因是财务上的。
And there's a wonderful sociologist at University of North Carolina Chapel Hill, Peggy Dilworth Anderson, who is black and who has studied these cultural issues. And she calls it cultural justifications for caregiving so that in black families it's viewed as part of a normal family role. It's not viewed as something where you're like giving something up. It's viewed as something that's expected and is talked about from early ages. And it is true that black families are less likely to place relatives in nursing homes. Some of those reasons are financial.
其中一些原因归咎于种族歧视。太常见的是，白人疗养院员工可能是种族主义者，而且，你知道的，这很有问题。但这也只是因为有一种将人留在家里非常强烈的偏好。我还要指出，配偶将人留在家里的可能性远远大于成年子女。配偶往往会为了把一个人留在家里而奋斗到最后一刻。那么请问您，海利博士，我们讨论了一部分关于它并非全都是负面的事实，那么有什么好处呢？我的意思是，从照顾中可以获得一些非常积极的事情。它们是什么？嗯，首先，如果你对美国人进行调查，当你调查时
Some of those reasons are due to racial discrimination. All too commonly, white nursing home staff may be racist, and, you know, that's problematic. But there's also just a very strong preference to keep. people at home. I'll also note that spouses have a much greater likelihood of keeping a person at home than do adult children. Spouses will tend to fight to the very bitter end to keep a person at home. So let me ask you then, Dr. Haley, what are the benefits we've talked a little bit about the fact that it's not all negative? I mean, there are some very positive things to be derived from caregiving. What are they? Well, first of all, if you survey Americans, when you survey
其中一些原因归咎于种族歧视。太常见的是，白人疗养院员工可能会有种族歧视，你知道的，这很有问题。但人们也非常强烈地倾向于让老人待在家里。我还要指出的是，配偶让患者留在家里的可能性比成年子女要大得多。配偶往往会战斗到最后一刻，以把患者留在家里。那么请问海利博士，我们之前讨论过照顾并非全然消极，其好处有哪些呢？我的意思是，照顾可以带来一些非常积极的结果。它们是什么？嗯，首先，如果你对美国人进行调查，当你调查时
Americans who have had experience as a caregiver, over 80% will say that it was a positive experience for them. And somewhere around 40 to 50% will say it was also a stressful experience. So the two things can coexist. But in our surveys, even of dementia caregivers, we'll find over 80% say that it has helped them to grow as a person, that it has helped them be more connected to other people. They feel they're more likely to have meaning in life and to think that they're doing something meaningful. And I'll mention as well, beyond the experiences that people have while they're a caregiver, you know, seeing the smile on mom's face when they are able to cook her favorite meal or take her out in nature, whatever they may do.
有照顾经历的美国人中，超过80%的人会表示这是一段积极的经历。大约40%到50%的人会表示这也是一段充满压力的经历。因此，这两者是可以并存的。但在我们的调查中，即使是痴呆症患者的照料者，也会发现超过80%的人表示，这帮助他们作为个人成长了，帮助他们与他人建立了更紧密的联系。他们觉得自己的生活更有意义，并且认为自己在做有意义的事情。我还要提一下，除了人们在担任照料者期间的经历之外，比如看到妈妈在他们能够为她做最喜欢的饭菜或带她去大自然时脸上露出的微笑，无论他们做什么。
We talk to families, and I've seen it in my own families. Once they've been through caregiving, they're so grateful that they did it. They're so grateful that they were there for mom, who was always there for them, or they were there for their spouse, who took care of them at prior times. So we don't want to paint this as a rose-colored glasses thing. Caregiving can be very stressful, but it's accompanied by these psychological benefits. And in my early years of research, I never thought to ask about this. And I never thought when working with clients to ask about it. And there's great research done by a psychologist Dr. Tak Cheng at University of Hong Kong. He's shown that if you add to standard psychoeducational intervention for caregivers, if you add a benefit-finding intervention, meaning that you teach the caregiver to notice
我们与许多家庭交谈过，我在自己的家族中也看到过这种情况。一旦他们经历了照料的过程，他们就会非常感激自己做到了这一点。他们非常感激自己能够陪伴在一直陪伴着他们的妈妈身边，或者陪伴着曾在过去照顾过他们的配偶。因此，我们并不想把这描绘成一幅玫瑰色的理想画面。照顾他人可能会带来巨大的压力，但它同时也伴随着这些心理上的益处。在我早期的研究中，我从未想过要询问这方面的情况。在与客户合作时，我也从未想过去询问这一点。香港大学的心理学家郑博士（Dr. Tak Cheng）做过非常棒的研究。他表明，如果在针对照料者的标准心理教育干预中，加入一项“寻找益处”的干预措施，也就是说，如果教导照料者去注意
the pleasures that their caregiver is having, if you get them to think about how their efforts are keeping mom out of a nursing home, that their efforts are helping their mom to be in a familiar place like their home. So these are, you can actually add that as part of the counseling, not that you're trying to ram people having rose-colored glasses, you know, into them, but caregivers will, if you ask about it, tell you about these, and we can promote that as a way of successful coping. So my last question, which will be highly unscientific, if you could wave a magic wand and make a change to our society right now that would basically put caregiving in a better place, what would that be?
照料对象所体验到的快乐，让他们思考自己的付出是如何让妈妈免于住进养老院的，他们的努力是如何帮助妈妈留在像家这样熟悉的地方的。所以这些，你实际上可以将其作为咨询的一部分加入进去，并不是说你要强行给人们灌输玫瑰色的乐观滤镜，但如果你问起的话，照料者会向你讲述这些，我们可以将其作为一种成功应对的方式来推广。所以我的最后一个问题，将是非常不科学的：如果你能挥动魔杖，对我们现在的社会做出一个改变，让照顾老人的工作处于一个更好的状态，那会是什么呢？
Well, I would say we need to value the caregiving role as something that is just as important and as productive as any other rule like employment. So, for example, one statistic that the ARP often offers is that the estimated economic value of caregiving is $600 billion a year. And the way they come to that figure is if you had to pay, if you had to pay, you know, nurses aides to do the jobs that are done by caregiving, that would be 38 million caregivers averaging 18 hours a week. That's $600 billion. But we don't value that. We don't see that as part of our gross domestic value. If you take off of work and you're providing that savings, which is ultimately savings to the community, you don't get any compensation for it.
嗯，我会说我们需要重视照料者的角色，将其视为与就业等任何其他角色同样重要、同样富有成效的角色。例如，美国退休人员协会（AARP）经常提供的一个统计数据是，照料工作的估计经济价值每年高达6000亿美元得出这一数字的方式是，如果你必须支付，如果你必须支付，你知道的，由护工来做照顾工作所做的事情，那将是3800万照料者，平均每周工作18小时。那是6000亿美元。但我们并不珍视这一点。我们不认为这是我们国内总价值的一部分。如果你请假去提供这种节省，而这最终是对社区的节省，你却得不到任何补偿。
So I think we had to value the role as a productive role. And that may include paying caregivers, which, for example, in the Veterans Administration, they offer payments to people who are caregivers. And there's other limited programs that do that. If we made it such that employers had to give people a certain amount of paid break time so that they can stay in the labor market, or, you know, the ability to take leave without being fired from their jobs, we've got to make caregiving a valued priority. And this is something that is really requires a major change in our ways of thinking, but we really need to do it.
因此，我认为我们必须将这一角色视为一个富有成效的角色。这可能包括向照料者支付报酬，例如，在美国退伍军人事务部，他们向担任照料者的人提供津贴。还有其他一些有限的项目也在这样做。如果我们能做到让雇主必须给员工一定数量的带薪休息时间，以便他们能够留在劳动力市场中，或者，你知道的，有请假而不会被解雇的能力，我们必须让照料工作成为一个受到重视的优先事项。而这确实需要我们的思维方式发生重大改变，但我们真的必须这样做。
Dr. Haley, I want to thank you for joining me today. I think the work that you're doing is critically important. Thank you. Thanks so much. And it was great to have a chance to talk with you today. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
海利博士，我想感谢你今天能来参加节目。我认为你正在做的工作至关重要。谢谢。非常感谢。今天能有机会与你交谈真是太好了。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 以及你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》以前的节目。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology
at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiyan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
at APA.org。《心理学对话》由莉·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音效剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Condiyan）。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。